oh hi last month's III Expo brought us
new news on a whole bunch of different
video games but did you ever feel like
something may have been missing while I
mean besides you know PlayStation Vita
games or Oh big Wii U announcements or I
guess a sense of decorum or any kind of
basic human dignity well no actually I'm
sorry wait what was really missing from
III was all the vaporware yes that's
right we here wired have long been on
top of new developments in the field of
imaginary products and video games are
no exception here are 5 video games that
should have shown up at e3 but didn't
coming in at number Five's rock stars
game agent announced in 2009 for the
PlayStation 3 this was supposed to be
the ultimate action game it was set in
the cold war in the 1970s it was about
political assassinations and espionage
it sounded really great take-two said
last year the game is still in
development okay so where is it number
four is half-life 2 episode 3 all the
way back in 2007 the second of the
episodic sequels to half-life 2 ended on
a massive cliffhanger what is the fate
of gordon freeman and alyx vance who the
hell knows hard as it is to believe it's
been almost five years with no third
episode I guess that's the downside of
Valve's famous horizontal org chart when
you don't have a boss there's no one of
leaning over your shoulder saying to
finish the freakin game already the
third game in our vaporware rundown is
Ubisoft's Beyond Good and Evil to the
original game released in 2003 was a big
cult hit it start a photojournalist
fighting against a corrupt government
really interesting stuff for the time
Ubisoft showed a trailer for Beyond Good
and Evil 2 back in 2008 but since then
it's refused to give any sort of major
updates before e3 creator michel ancel
implied that we won't see the game until
the next generation of gaming consoles
meaning that we have a while to wait
second place goes to Sony's The Last
Guardian this heartwarming tale of a boy
and his giant eagle cat thing is the
latest game from the team that brought
us the incredible games
and shadow of the colossus sony took the
wraps off this PlayStation 3 game at its
2009 III press conference but it's still
not here it's had official release dates
before but it keeps getting bumped back
the series creator phooey total way to
actually left Sony and is finishing the
game as a contractor not the most
inspiring news at e3 the website
Eurogamer caught up with a Sony
executive who said the game was having
technical difficulties oh well I guess
that explains it what technical that
your Sony your sony Sony how are you
having technical difficulties with the
PlayStation 3 this is like McDonald's
saying they forget where the ketchup
goes anyway number 1 on our list is of
course the imaginary make-believe game
Final Fantasy Versus 13 for the
PlayStation 3 hard as it is to believe
square enix announced this action RPG
spin-off of the final fantasy series way
back at e3 of 2006 since then there's
never even been a playable demo producer
Tetsuya Nomura keeps giving project
updates to the Japanese magazine famitsu
most recently he said that the next time
we see vs 13 it'll be running in real
time yeah after six years I certainly
hope so thanks for joining us this week
on game life we will be back next week
with more video games that actually
exist
you